HAVE TO GET IN FRONT OF HIM AND
REALLY GET INSIDE POSITION TO
GET SCORING OPPORTUNITIES AND AT
CK AT A CROSS, AND TAKING A
SWIPE ATINE RIGHT HERE AND BEFOE
THE GOAL A NEW STICK.
PENGUINS WITH CARTER, WALKING
IN, SAVE.
WORKED OUT OF THE ZONE GUENTZEL
AHEAD AND HERE COMEEAL, BUT THIS
McLEOD, GETTING TO BARB I
DON'T McLEOD,
JUST DETET ST. LOUIS.
>> Dano: JOE SERELL AS WAS
TIME FORS HAD THE BEST
CHANCE ON THIS BAN, THE CROSSOV.
IF HE WOULD HAVE SCORED, THIS
WOULD HAVE BEEN UNBELIEVABLE.
BIG SAVE SCORE SHEET, THE
DEVILS WITH THE LEAD.
HUGHES AND IT'S ALL ABOUT T BY R
CONCEDING THE OPENING
CROSBY NOW IN TWO.
VESEY IS DENIED.
VESEY WITH THE UP HERE BY RUHWEL
AGAIN.
HE'LL DROP IT BACK.
MATHESON DRIVES, S A LOT ON IT.
RIGHT OVER THE G JERSEY DEVILS
HOCKEY IS BROUGHT TO YOU BY
RWJ BARNABAS HEALTH, THE
IT WAS REDIRECTED PAST GILLIES,
ALL IF TENTS AND PURPOSES, IT'S
LIKE -- INTENTS AND PURPOSES,
IT'S IN!
TIE GAME!
K AT IT.
NG A FALL DURING THE
ALL-STAR B IT MIGHT HAVE
SQUEEZED UNDERNEATHIT BACK.
RODRIGUES TO THE CIRCLE,
KAPANEN, THE REDIRECT. DRAW, THE
PENGUINS FORCE THIS OUTRE!
BRIAN BOYLE, BACK AT PRUDENTIAL
CENTER, WITH THE GO-AHEAD GOAL.
RIGHT IN FRONT, CLEANS IT
HERE COMES NICO BACK THE OTHER
WAY. PETTERSSON FOR
PITTSBURGH, A FIRE-IN.
APPROACHING THE MIDWAY MARK OF
THTH TEAMS, AS
LETANG BUYS SOME TIME.
DE Steve: CARTER CLEARED THE
PUCK OFF THE FACEOFF.
DEVILS POWER-PLAY BROUGHT TO YOU
BY
HEREGOES OFF THE WALL, ZACHA CAT
HANDLE